m
[Musique]
la présidente et les élus sont en colère
alors que l'état devrait verser au titre
du fonds de soutien aux départements en
difficulté 200 millions d'euros
c'est la répartition de cette somme qui
laisse perplexe les critères
d'évaluation ont en effet privilégié les
territoires nationaux au détriment de la
réunion résultat au lieu de 16 millions
d'euros les réunionnais devront se
contenter que de 4,9 millions d'euros on
est en colère parce qu'on a été
maltraité pas considérer on met en place
des critères d'attribution d'une aide
exceptionnelle et on met d'un côté la
france métropolitaine
de l'autre côté les dom c'est plus d'un
milliard d'euros qui n'a pas été
compensée depuis 2002 parler d'un
résultat le département dû puiser dans
ses fonds propres pour continuer à
verser les allocations individuelles de
solidarité c'est-à-dire le revenu de
solidarité active mais également
l'allocation personnalisée à l'autonomie
et les autres prestations sociales
destinées entre autres personnes en
situation de handicap
elle attend que le gouvernement nous
dise un habitant chez nous ne vaut pas 5
euros
c'est ce que le gouvernement vient de
nous dire alors que ce même habitant en
france métropolitaine
il vaut 20 euros nous sommes dans une
situation inéquitable et j'ai presque
envie dire sur le principe de légalité
constitutionnelle
il y à là pour moi une faute nous sommes
des français à part entière
si nous sommes des départements apa
alors donnez nous d'autres règles sur le
plan économique qui permette à la
réunion où il ya un fort taux de chômage
d'avoir aussi d'autres critères pour
aider l'économie réunionnaise
nous voulons avoir les mêmes critères
que n'importe quel département de france
c'est tout ce que nous réclamons nou lé
pas plus nou lé pa moin mai respekt anou
la collectivité devra donc supporter les
11 millions de dépenses supplémentaires
la présidente nassimah dindar et les
élus de la majorité en appelle à la
responsabilité de l'état les conseils
départementaux l'on envoyait un courrier
à la ministre d outre-mer et au député
réunionnais
pour qu'ils interviennent face à cette
situation d'injustice sociale
[Musique]